Hello Freak bitches.
We never found that video of the evergreen
professor throwing his hands around.
Oh yeah, there's one video.
I'm pretty sure it's in,
but I need to like double check and
listen to make sure it's the part they're
talking. Okay. Cause it was getting
line and sent it to me and I had it,
they sent it cued up like right where
it is and it's, it's so hilarious.
There's probably, you know what
I, it's queued up in a website.
If you Google Evergreen,
uh, at, what is he,
the president of evergreen pro.
Oh I'm in evergreen hand
motions are a micro aggression.
Google that emotions are a microphone.
They have it,
there's a website for sure that as an
article where they show the video and they
have it queued up and when it's queued
up you can see the kids laughing when
they get the teacher to put his
hands behind his back. Well see it.
But that's them not understanding
what they really are looking for.
Part of it feels like ha ha major do it.
And another part says that's
a microaggression. Don't
do that. Where it's like,
if you believe that, that don't laugh
at someone for not doing it anymore.
What they're doing is just enjoying power.
These kids have taken over the school,
right? Yeah. That's it. Okay.
Gimme some gimme some volume. Yes.
That's not appropriate.
He's apologizing.
Walks up to the presence. Like put your
hands down. Put his hands to his side.
Yes, dude. And they're laughing at him.
Pastors were slaves and
your ancestors were not.
Your ancestors came here. I'll free
choice and decided to bring along people.
Oh, they're not out their own free
will to work and build this country.
My Dad was letting you know that slavery
still have repercussions in society
today and that is what we're here about.
Three for questions right in
front. Applause over. Thank you.
Yeah. She seems to not
know. Oh, there she is.
Trying to get off and what does he
do about that? He's clapping as well.
He's clapping too. He needs
a, he needs to seriously stop.
He's clapping too. Like he had
a really good point. You can't,
it's something we know about, you
know, just okay. The version of that,
that super liberal left is the feminists,
you know that version of that.
This is it.
There's a version of that which is
just the feminists like that version of
feminists. That erosion. Yeah.
There's like there's versions,
there's versions of masculine lists
too. Right? There's one built. Right.
I guess is it though? I don't know. I
don't really understand. I don't know.
Seems to me like the alt right for more,
more than a lot of what
they're doing is having fun.
It doesn't seem like a troll. Like some
of it's like just straight trolling.
A lot of it is, he was talking to
us. I can't believe it. I was like,
can't you believe it? Well maybe
it was a job. I mean like Milo,
Milo Yiannopoulos. Surely
I got some so mad. Yeah.
Milo is so like, it's so theatrical.
So much of what he's doing,
he seems like he's having,
because I love it when they get on
somebody and he just like shit on them a
little bit.
Like at like someone's a god to them.
All of a sudden Beyonce after lemonade,
things like that.
If you shit on them a little bit,
you could get people so fucking angry
or you know, it's great. It's great.
It's never been a time like this art fair.
We get so many morons mad at you.
I love it. Um, but yeah,
but so what I've noticed is
that all of the Super Liberal,
okay. You know how like American sports
fans are Kinda dumb. How dare you?
Not all the leave.
I'm home more so than other places,
but we're not very thought out. Rude
political like analysis isn't that smart?
The same way our liberal left
or feminism is some of the,
it's feminism in the world.
Like other ones are more thought out
and more interesting and more like just
thoughtful in general. Dude, I think you
left America became a fucking turncoat.
That's what I'm hearing. I'm
hearing a bunch of bullshit. Yeah.
Yeah. So what do you think though?
You should hear people talking.
They're way smarter than the
people we have. Like, like,
so our people are just dumber saying
this microaggression shit. Right.
That's us having too
much fucking free time.
Is that what is that is you've left
behind what's actually wrong and you're
jumping off, which is a lot.
There's a lot wrong. Yeah.
So like worry about that and calmed down.
Micro gets you guys.
It's not like there's better
shit to do so you don't,
shouldn't worry about what actually
bothers you. This shut and bother you.
You know,
take that same venom and put it into
something that's actually happening.
There's this forced, okay, but
like that girl that's circumcision,
the girl that set up there and it's
like your ancestors were not slaves.
We weren't proud of your mind were,
you know,
in slavery has repercussions and then
everybody starts clapping and it's like
you are, you're right. But what
is the point? What are we doing?
Like, yeah, it's all obviously ancestors.
Like when do we get over
this ancestor thing?
Like how many generations in do we do we
just treat people as individuals and as
people? What do they want? Some
people got an advantage for sure.
White people got an advantage
for sure. Okay. But it's not,
it's, it's, it's more so,
but it's not 100% of the time. So
if I came from, uh, from, uh, uh,
divorced household, I
didn't, right. You know,
and my dad wasn't around and
my dad beat my mom, you know,
that can be a way worse and harder
experience then the Cosby kids. Right.
You know? Right. Yeah. So it's
like, just because you're this,
it might make the odds harder for you,
but it's not 100%,
but there's an origins thing and one of
the origins that every black kid has to
face that when they think about it,
is it someone down the line was a
slave and they're not slaves anymore.
But that's why people who
look like him are here.
They're all here because someone
brought them over here in chains. Yeah.
And there's still remnants of
that. Right. And there's some,
there's gotta be a weird self esteem
or a self identity issue attached to
knowing that everybody knows
that your ancestors were slaves.
And there's a certain,
like there's a certain thing that
people do when someone has something and
someone else wants it.
Okay.
You, if you have a a group
of people that's different,
it's like really easy to almost
think of them as not you.
Like that's how they've justified wars.
That's how so many people I
by dehumanizing the other,
you know,
and this,
this thing that has to
balance out that I guess is,
I guess just the echoes of that.
It's like we have to get so
many generations away from the,
from people being slaves and any
repercussions of it socially I cannot,
we have to get so far away that it doesn't
factor in anymore where we don't care.
Okay. That's well expressed
for sure. Yeah. I like that.
That kind of like calm
way to explain something.
Rarely gets put out and of course
screaming and he's yelling. You know why?
Like you're not teaching anyone anything.
The biggest problem on the left and
the right, but the ones that are angry,
the angry mobs is they never seek to
educate. They only seek to like punish.
Also grandstand.
They seem sure want to make this bigger
here and the lady's voice she was going
for audience. The audience clap
two, three times. Didn't get it.
And it was like all keep going.
She's seen Oprah.
She knows how to manipulate a crowd. She
knows how to get those people riled up.
Yeah. Well listen man, that's
part of being a person.
Like that's half the reward for saying
something that's right is the love that
you get from people when you say that
it's right and they recognize it and they
go yes. So people get
addicted to that. Yes.
So they constantly do things that they
think are at least perceived as being
right and they get very vocal with things
when they perceive those things are
going to get a very big reaction for
standing up against them and it becomes
this moral high ground sort of grand
grandstanding peacocking sort of a thing
where they just are constantly trying to
let everyone even know how uncool it is
to do this and how wrong it is to do that.
Like settle the fuck down.
Yeah. Like weird, weird thing.
And then sometimes they'll see
something that doesn't quite fit in.
Like they'll sit there was trying to make,
you know how they make rape a broader
and broader and broader. Oh yeah.
Which is really does think
does a disservice to ripe.
It does to be able to make it seem like,
anyway,
there was some coercion is rape where
if we talk someone into it, yes,
that's right. And then a bunch of men
was like, oh, well if that's true,
then I've been raped a bunch of times.
This is the super liberal left. It's like,
oh,
we don't want to make that.
We were on wanting to make you
be able to evict them, so, okay,
that's no longer rape.